okay along the same lines I'm getting
martial law questions and they relate
not just to coronavirus but to the
election and the question is David will
Donald Trump declare martial law and
suspend the election due to coronavirus
we already talked about this a little
bit earlier this week when we got a
voicemail so martial law is when
military control is placed over civilian
functions of government so this would be
if there's an emergency a major disaster
terrorist attack in an occupied
territory etc it is very complicated
legal territory when it comes to things
that require that that are sort of bound
by the law the election date and when
electors need to formally cast their
ballots for the candidate that one on
Election Day is prescribed in the
Constitution and so you would need
Congress to say something about the
election being moved to a different day
this year December 14th is when the
electors are supposed to vote if
Massachusetts votes for Biden the
electors on December 14th need to go and
say Massachusetts casts our electors for
Joe Biden at the delegate counting
convention whatever to go beyond
December 14 with that it would take an
act of Congress or something
extraordinary now where it starts to get
dicey is if you have martial law and
civilian courts are closed imagine that
there is such a lockdown that martial
law is put in place and it's not just
restaurants and public transit that are
shut down civilian court courts are
closed martial law could dictate that
military courts start to get involved in
adjudicating some of these things it's
conceivable that moving the election
beyond when December 14th would be the
date where the electors vote up could
end up going to courts if the civilian
courts are down it could conceivably go
to a military court that this is
insanely unlikely now I want to remind
folks who like the idea
of martial law to keep Trump in power
number one either way even if there's no
election Donald Trump's term
constitutionally ends on January 20 2021
at that point again it's contested
exactly the logistics but the Speaker of
the House would become President of the
United States that is scheduled to be
Nancy Pelosi that's number one and so I
don't know that trumpets are really well
served by focusing on this number two
typically when martial law is declared
guns are confiscated okay again I don't
know that the pro-trump gun nuts are
going to be thrilled if the martial law
they believe might keep Trump in is also
used as a justification to start
confiscating their guns it will probably
get ugly checkpoints typically get set
up in cities it's all very very bad so
let's all not be hoping for that
regardless of whether it might keep
Trump in office an extra month or
something it's unlikely to do that and
these are exactly the type of questions
that really expose the degree of
uncertainty and fear that is going on
and I sympathize with that but let's all
work together here think not just of
yourself but of other people do what the
experts are asking you to do and
hopefully we can start to turn this
curve find an inflection point and turn
things in the right direction so we can
have an election on schedule we can have
a peaceful transfer of power if that is
what the voters decide